hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Samantha a
Chevelle
we're gonna watch the trailer today for
Marco Polo now if this is anything like
the pool game I am so excited Marco Polo
the build of an intervention our courses
through your veins I can say this you
will enjoy a the greatest adventure of
all
this is immunity
Wow
oh I am so watching that I have a
Netflix account oh you guys you better
hold me to it that I watched [ __ ] I am
so gonna watch that that was so good and
I love the fact that I mean yes we're
joking around beginning Marco Polo and
all that but it's based off of the real
Marco Polo yeah person I know the story
I know it's so well what's the story
it's clearly defining the trailer I just
be repeating what the trailer said yeah
then repeat it that would be wasting
time well yeah I mean I could tell you
like other stuff that they didn't talk
about not cinematography looks excellent
story group production design really
good production design Ryan the action
looks cool I so do I'm just telling you
you lie what was your accent I don't
know it's the lie along how you're
making fun of the Asian people in the
trade off you die you like you don't
know a story
you're not story at all you're making
fun of the Asian people in this awesome
you don't know that star in your life
well what's the story seriously yeah for
our viewers please explain Marco Polo
was only like the greatest adventure
that there ever was I mean that pretty
much sums it up so the fact that they're
now doing a show based upon this man who
went out into the unknown on these crazy
adventures and over into Asia is pretty
remarkable
Wow that makes its trailer a lot better
that's pretty cool I thought what a gang
is gone I mean I get the way you're
talking about all right well let's be
serious the greatest Explorer was
Abraham Lincoln when he found America so
if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects where we
give you awesome facts about history
that are so true if they're coming from
me samantha has a channel now created
videos starting next week watch it
check out her channel subscribe please
I'll have some fun exciting things
coming oh my god didn't you know that I
didn't know that I would get beat all
the time when my mom would catch me
using her makeup one carranza yo Ryan
love the channel my man could get shout
out also was wondering yo could do the
Fast & Furious 7 trailer reaction yes I
did this is posted 14 hours ago it would
have been posted already by the time you
left this showing me one wow that you
are not as dedicated to checking your
emails whenever one of my videos comes
in that hurts hurts doesn't it yeah it
hurts it really does hurt get hit that
refresh button nothing wrong with the
refresh button okay Samantha okay Jesus
Christ I'm not really religious or
anything but when I say Jesus Christ too
many times I'm like cheese and rice that
at least sounds delicious
yeah and Wang Carranza eats at bamboo
done looped him back in Liam Thomas
peachy
what a great channel slash format you
guys are absolutely brilliant you know
what yeah brilliant that that is the
word I would use to describe it's guy
knows what he's talking about
watching you made me finally bite the
bullet oh ouch and start a review series
here on YouTube keep up the good work
guys PS a shout out would make my day
and you could have my firstborn - yeah -
a baby
find me at paes164.com
thank you you want to shout out he's
posted it here Timothy Michael hey Ryan
I wanted to let you know a new Battle of
the five armies trailer gets released
this Wednesday well Ryan
I mean Timothy I am right Veronica
Veronica the new Hobbit trailer is
getting released on ones they do want to
watch it with me okay cool
damn deal done thanks and if I hear any
other news I can send it your way thanks
Timothy Michael that deserves a
shout-out he has earned a shout out
shout has now been put out ooh
it rhymes that's what shut make shout
out the word so cool this is a rhyme you
know like Marco Polo like homophobe Oh